so true we all can make a difference the
media is all available to us and every
time that we don't speak up and we don't
get involved it's uh one for the jihadis
and one less for free speech um our next
uh speaker Robert Spencer U hardly needs
an introduction he is a very complex
writer
blogger and student of
Islam he founded and is the director of
jihad watch he's uh affiliated with the
David Howard Freedom Center we're very
proud of
Z and he's the author of 10 books
including the New York time bestseller
the truth about Muhammad and the
politically incorrect guide to Islam in
the Crusades both reg generary
Publications his latest book he
co-authored with Pamela
Geller Robert has also written 11
monographs and well over 300 articles
about Jihad and Islamic terrorism in
addition um
Robert
has has has been featured on numer
numerous TV shows he's really uh an an
expert in Islam he knows the facts he's
not making this stuff up he's a student
of it people would like to pretend that
they know more than Islam about hea very
few people do his books are filled with
facts uh they're not myth
he dispels the myths uh and U as many of
you know the Quran is a very complex
document that if you want to study it
you just can't pick up you know an
average Quran and read it and take it at
its face value a lot of nuances to
it I think that uh one thing on Robert's
bio that stood out for me the most was
under his frequently asked questions one
of the questions on his website it says
why should I believe what you say about
Islam and Robert Spencer says pick up
any of my books and you will see they
are made up largely of quotations from
Islamic jihadists and the traditional
Islamic sources to which they appeal to
justify violence and terrorism my work
sheds light on what these sources say
the evidence stands by itself readers
can evaluate it for themselves I would
of course be happy to debate any scholar
about Islam and Jihad this is a standing
invitation ladies and gentlemen very few
people have have the knowledge the
intellect and the courage to stand up
and debate Islamic scholars about Islam
I give you Robert
[Applause]
[Music]
Spencer thank you very much uh Craig for
that very generous introduction and it
brings to mind an interesting point and
that is that I don't actually have any
plans to debate any Islamic scholars at
any time in the future I have issued uh
invitations to many of them to debate me
over the years and uh most of them
refuse which uh I think is indicative in
itself of how strong they know their
position to be in reality but I am
actually debating uh later this month a
Catholic scholar who has written a book
his name is Peter creft and uh he's
actually an old professor of mine and
he's written a new book called between
Allah and Jesus and and the book uh is
all about how wonderful Islam is and how
much Christians need to learn from
Muslims and so it's I think just rather
indicative of the fix we're in and
indicative of the general cultural
climate that uh Pamela was describing so
vividly in regard to the Ground Zero
mosque that it really is uh seen to be a
matter of uh generosity tolerance
broad-mindedness to in effect enable the
most repressive ideology on Earth and to
uh run interference for it and make
excuses for it is considered to be uh
tolerant and broadminded whereas
standing for freedom is considered to be
racist and
bigoted and that's just the upside down
world that we live in and of course
chief on the uh upside down front is the
president of the United States uh I was
talking to a friend uh very
recently a uh Jewish man who was
pointing out out that Obama had said a
few years back in that interview with
George Stephanopoulos uh he had referred
to my Muslim faith and I said oh come on
that was just a slip of the tongue and
he said well listen consider this I
would never make a slip of the tongue to
refer to my Christian faith or my
Buddhist
faith I'm Jewish and I'm proud of being
Jewish and that's what I am and I would
never make that kind of
mistake and I thought that there was a
lot of Truth to that that there really
is a something very strange in regard to
Barack Obama's connections to Islam and
this is something that Pamela Geller was
on way before anybody else back in 2007
I'm actually kind of embarrassed to say
I made a video which you can still find
online but don't bother uh uh taking up
the rumors about Obama's uh Muslim faith
and I said that's a lot of hooie and as
a matter of fact that's the screenshot
of it with me standing by a sign that
says
that's a lot of hooey and actually
interestingly enough talking about media
bias here again just as an aside The
Washington Post actually picked up on
that and completely turned it around
360° and said I was responsible for
starting the rumors that Obama was
secretly a
Muslim which was really sort of absurd
because I was trying to debunk them or
to Bunk them as raaza aan would say but
in any
case the the
the parallel track at the same time in
early 2007 and going on through '08 and
up to the election was uh at Atlas
shrugs where Pamela was uncovering all
kinds of information about how Obama was
registered as a Muslim in school in
Indonesia and she was the first one with
the registration form and how he uh uh
confirmation that he went to Quran class
which was only open to Muslim Students
in Indonesia at the time that he was
there and various other information
which I was
discounting and it wasn't until she
asked me to work on this book with her
and I started looking at all
this that she explained to me what it
was all about it really doesn't matter
ultimately whether Barack Obama secretly
professes the Islamic faith now or not
and ultimately because he's not being
very forthcoming about it nobody really
knows except Barack Obama but I can tell
you this also his saying that he's a
Christian is not to say that he's not a
Muslim now that may seem confusing but
if you read the Quran and study Islam
you will see that Islam positions itself
as the true and pure form of both
Judaism and
Christianity and so a Muslim has no
trouble saying I'm a Jew and I'm a
Christian we saw Imam rouf say I'm a Jew
I've always been a Jew and everybody
said oh he's so tolerant and
Multicultural and modern actually he was
just being a Pious and Orthodox Muslim
but in any case whether Obama actually
professes the Islamic faith or not is
irrelevant what is relevant is how it
has formed his perceptions of the world
his attitudes and his values and he did
as Pamela documented grow up in an
Islamic milu with Muslim parents and he
has clearly as his policies have
indicated over the last 2 years clearly
IDE the world view of the Islamic world
to the extent that he demonizes Israel
which is the fundamental bogy for the
for the Islamic world because its very
existence is an attack on
Islam you know that in the Quran the
worst enemies of the Muslims are the
Jews and it is said very clearly in the
Quran that they will be persecuted and
debased and under the curse of Allah
forever for not accepting Muhammad is a
prophet and so the idea of a thriving
Jewish state that is on land that once
belonged to the house of Islam and thus
also by Islamic theology belongs to the
house of Islam
forever the idea that that state would
exist is an attack on Islam and an
insult to Islam because it contradicts
quranic
imperatives and so this then you see how
Barack Obama treats Benjamin nety
and how he's trying to Strongarm the
Jewish State into accepting a
Palestinian state which everybody with
an ounce of sense will know will become
yet another base for Jihad attacks
against
Israel and you see how he is
absolutely on the other hand supine in
the face of the nuclear threat from the
Islamic Republic of Iran and he doesn't
seem to think that's any problem at all
he's much more upset about Jews building
hom in Israel than he is about mulas
building bombs in
[Music]
Iran why well it all goes back to these
core attitudes that he has imbibed from
the beginning and this is why also of
course it was inevitable that he was
going to come out in favor of the
groundzero mosque there just wasn't any
other option open to him there wasn't
any doubt about it whatsoever what was
only surprising perhaps was that he took
so long to do it but maybe he was
waiting for that wonderful ifar dinner
so that he could Drive the point home
about how important it is for us to be
supportive and open and welcoming toward
Islam and so consider
this take this for a second what if rou
really is everything that he says he
is what if he is a moderate and uh
peaceful and tolerant individual who
really wants to build a mosque of peace
and Reconciliation and
Harmony what what if he is okay let's
say he is for a minute forget his
Sinister
expression
consider that the Imam rou and no other
Imam in the world
either he can't control the discourse in
the Islamic world he cannot control how
that mosque will be perceived among
Muslims because after all there are over
a billion
Muslims often the numbers are wildly
inflated but they're proba they are
around a billion and not all of them
have heard of the Imam Ru not all of
them are ever going to hear of him not
all of them are going to receive his
communic and fall into line so how are
they going to understand the triumphal
mosque well I submit to you they will
understand it based on what they see in
their own environment what they see in
their own City in their own countries
and what do they see let's tally
up how many MOS
are built on the sites of destroyed
churches synagogues and Hindu
temples thousands literally thousands
upon thousands there's actually a book a
very large I believe it's a two volume
book by the great Hindu historian Cedar
rang goel that is just a list of all the
Hindu temples that were destroyed and
mosques built over them or converted
from being Hindu temples into mosques
and you go into the Middle East you go
into North
Africa you find thousands same thing of
churches and synagogues destroyed or
converted into mosques you know the pope
a few years back you may remember went
to Syria and he prayed at the tomb of
John the Baptist which is in the umad
mosque in Damascus why is the tomb of
John the Baptist who's a Christian Saint
in a mosque well because it used to be
the Cathedral of John the
Baptist
anyway thousands upon thousands of these
places built as triumphal mosques on
these sites that were the cherished
sites as Pamela said of conquered people
how many mosques of Peace Harmony and
Reconciliation are there in the Islamic
world that are built on the site of an
earlier Islamic Jihad attack in order to
build Bridges with the people who were
attacked Z none zero never happened
never happened in 1400 years of Islamic
history so you're Joe Muslim Yousef
Muslim Yousef Islam Cat
Stevens you are in Damascus or Cairo or
Islamabad or Jakarta or daras Salon or
wherever and there's the mosque and
everybody knows it used to be a church
or everybody knows there used to be a
church here Christians here and now
there's this Mosque of
Triumph and you hear about the mosque in
New York at Ground Zero and not near
Ground Zero the landing gear from one of
those planes crashed right into that
building and fell five stories to the
basement that's why they want that
building make no mistake that building
is part of the attack
site and you hear about this mosque
being built there on the attack site
what are you going to think it is it's a
farone conclusion it doesn't matter if
the IM R is Captain
Kangaroo there is no way he's going to
be able to put that narrative across and
of course he doesn't really want to he
knows that it will be a triumphal mosque
as a matter of fact the very name
Cordoba indicates that but you see it a
lot of you are nodding and you know what
Corda really means but think about that
it was chosen
because he wanted both connotations to
apply he knew
maybe some of you have read or some of
you have heard of the book the ornament
of the World by Mar
menal and it is the formost whitewash of
Islamic Spain if she really is
responsible Professor menal yes I'm
calling you out Professor let's have a
debate um she uh is responsible for
putting forward this myth that Islamic
Spain was a protom multiculturalist
paradise where Jews Christians and
Muslims lived together in peace and
Harmony and everybody was happy and the
lion laid down with the lamb and
everything it was great except it's
fictional and as a matter of fact she is
honest enough to put it's only on one
page near the beginning of the book well
yes Jews and Christians did not enjoy
equality of rights in the Islamic State
uh States in Spain but they were uh
second class demies they were deprived
of essential rights under the teachings
of Islamic law she does grant you
that but the reality is see that this
myth has become very popular in the
United States today and you ask the
average person they say oh yes well you
know we do have a little bit of a
problem with with the people who have
twisted and hijacked the religion of
Peace today but we all know Muslim Fain
was so great and wonderful except it
wasn't but the fact that people think it
was is why he chose the na so would
think oh isn't that lovely we're going
to have a new Cordoba in lower Manhattan
and Jews and Christians in Muslims will
dance together and sing together and
swim together and play together and
it'll be
great and then he knows that outside the
United
States in Jakarta and Islam Abad and
Cairo and Damascus and Dar Salam and
Nairobi and all the rest of them they
will say oh Cordoba oh this is a beach
head for the Islamic Invasion and
conquest of the United States of course
because they know what happened in
Muslim Spain historical memories are
much longer in the Islamic world they
are in the west and they don't read
Maria
Rosa
so does Barack Obama know this does he
care of course Barack Obama is aware of
all these things how could he not when
he grew up in Indonesia when he grew up
in an Islamic context have imbibed these
things and understand these things so
what is he really all about what is
really his ultimate plan it is something
something that unfortunately I cannot
give you the answer to in full I wish I
could but I do think that it is
extraordinarily
disquieting and something that we should
all be aware of that he is already doing
the bidding of the organization of the
Islamic conference the organization of
the Islamic conference is 56 States plus
the Palestinian Authority it is the
largest voting block at the United
Nations today the United Nations
essentially does the bidding of the OIC
unless it is stopped by The veto from
the United States or some other
power and the organization of the
Islamic conference has been working on
for the last few years a concerted
initiative to limit the freedom of
speech in the west now what Craig said
that uh dissent is essential to the
freedom of speech and not only is that
true but also freedom of speech Beach is
designed to protect
descent that's the whole point of it
that instead of having a tyrant in the
government who can do and say whatever
he wants and get away with whatever he
wants with no
descent the descenders are protected by
the freedom of speech so that the Tyrant
can't get away with what he wants to get
away with but he always has to deal with
a loyal
opposition and so freedom of speech is a
fundamental bullwark against
tyranny in this case it's the tyranny of
Islamic supremacism the organization of
the Islamic conference wants to destroy
the freedom of speech in the west
because they know they've noticed that
there are a few people who are
connecting the dots and saying wait a
minute there's something about Islam
that's causing
violence and a cultural supremacism that
is asserting the principle that wherever
Islamic law and Western laws can
contradict each other it is Western laws
that have to give way
and the organization of the Islamic
conference does not like us to talk
about this because then people wake up
people hear about it they understand
what's going on and then they will like
many of you here stand up and start
taking action and they don't want that
so they want to make it illegal
impossible for us to speak about these
elements of Islam under the guise of
criminalizing what they call religious
hatred now nobody really is in favor of
hatred not even me nobody really likes
hate speech but what is hate speech hate
is in the eye of the beholder if I say
Islam is not a religion of peace and
Islam the Quran counsels Warfare against
and the subjugation of unbelievers under
a global Islamic State those are
statements of fact but they would be
hate speech in many many contexts
including ABC
News and
so if that's hate speech and it's
impossible for us to say then we are
rendered mute and defenseless in the
face of the advancing Jihad threat and
Barack
Obama actually co-sponsored the United
States co-sponsored with
Egypt in the summer of
2009 a resolution calling upon UN member
States to criminalize religious hatred
and so for the first time the United
States government went on record
opposing the United States
Constitution at the UN and you notice
didn't get a whole lot of
coverage but the the the
ultimate effect the ultimate goal of the
Obama Administration is extraordinarily
disquieting and there's so many enemies
of the freedom of speech that he has in
his administration so many different
people different officials and they're
all uh profiled in the book who have
come out against the freedom of speech
come out in favor of restrictions of the
freedom of
speech he's got them all over his
administration and they're
working so this is the time to stand up
we have to as Pamela said beat them in
November and beat them again in 2012 or
really the situation could be more dire
than we could imagine and I'm sorry to
leave you on that note but this is not
just a call to pessimism or a call to
Gloom it is a call to
action and if we value the greatest
civilization on earth and the greatest
country on Earth then this is the time
to stand up and defend it or all will be
lost thank
[Music]
[Applause]
you